this morning the number of coronavirus
deaths worldwide is nearing
3 million and cases here in the united
states are on the rise despite ongoing
vaccination efforts
about 40 percent of americans have
received at least one dose of the covet
vaccine
and nearly one quarter of those are
fully vaccinated
but as tom hansen reports new variants
of the virus are fueling the latest
surge in cases
the good news is vaccine rollout is
moving along
at a great pace the bad news is the
variants are emerging
everywhere dr david ho has his eye on
yet another variant
identified in his columbia university
lab in new york city
it's concerning because it's spreading
at a rate that is
on par with the uk variant and we know
the uk variant
is more transmissible and more
more lethal from coast to coast places
like this washington lab visited friday
by the state's governor
are hunting for variants caused by
mutations in the coronavirus
we clearly are in the danger zone
vaccine makers are
preparing for booster shots to combat
the variants at least the ones that are
known
ongoing already clinical trials
looking at a boost of the original
wild-type
virus vaccine as well as a boost
with a variant specific the biden
administration is behind the push
announcing yesterday 1.7 billion dollars
will be spent
on detection of variants we need more
capacity
in our public health system to identify
and track these mutations
at the same time johnson and johnson's
vaccine
only available since march remains on
hold while cases of blood clots are
investigated to see if that vaccine
caused the complications a cdc advisory
committee is scheduled to meet next week
to report on continued use for cbs this
morning saturday
tom hansen new york